as you may have heard just coming into
our broadcast tonight
the president has made a very important
decision
he has decided to at least temporarily
freeze
any additional funding for the world
health organization he says they must
improve
or they will now face a permanent freeze
in a letter to the leader of the w.h.o
the president reminded him that
back on april 14 he suspended u.s
contributions to the world health
organization
pending an investigation by the
administration over the organization's
failed response to the covet 19 outbreak
he says that review has concluded that
yes
they made the proper decision that
lacking
in further improvements and more
transparency the
funds will continue to be frozen so
again recapping
shannon uh money for the who the world
health organization
remains frozen president trump says they
won't get another cent
until they make substantive changes back
to you
well the pressure is on and it's growing
in the international community kevin
thank you for keeping us up to date you
bet